what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar and today i'm going to be
talking about the legend himself
hitachi chiha itachi has always been one
of the most interesting characters to me
and since a lot of you requested a
detailed video about hitachi
here we are this one is focusing on his
powers and abilities from birth up to
the point where he left konoha after
killing his clan
but i'd also like to make one about his
power afterwards a video about
adult itachi if you will so if that's
something you'd like to see make sure to
smash that like button let's see if we
can hit
5 000 likes on this one if you haven't
be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future naruto videos
and leave suggestions in the comments
for what video topics you would like me
to cover
next as usual spoilers are fair game now
without further ado
let's jump into it hitachi has been
called itachi of the shutting gun
and clan killer itachi he is the older
brother of sasuke
and the son of fugaku chiha who was the
head of the
jihad clan and the leader of the konoha
military police force
we know in naruto that op parents tend
to have ob
children and fugaku was notably
considered to be a rare genius
fugaku earned the nickname wikitai
fugaku and his reputation struck
fear into the hearts of enemy ninja he
was compared to minato namikaze
and the legendary three and some
strongly felt like he should have been
the fourth hokage
this is all extremely impressive and
what's even more impressive
is that itachi was clearly even more
talented than his fearsome father
even as a child in the hitachi novels
fugaku's ninja pride is often threatened
by his firstborn son's exceptional
talents
hitachi grew up quick at only 4 his
father showed him the horrors of war
up close hitachi was sickened by what he
saw and he promised himself that he
would change the world
thus at only 4 years old he embarked on
the path to become the strongest so that
he could bring peace to the world
although fugaku shouldn't get any father
of the year awards
he did give hitachi a sense of urgency
which accelerated his growth as a ninja
shisui uchiha who was considered to be
the strongest uchiha of his time
complimented hitachi on his mastery of
shuriken jutsu aka the art of throwing
shuriken kunai and other projectiles
when hitachi was only five years old
also when he was five during ninetales
attack there was an incident with an
enormous rock that was large enough to
easily crush
a mother and her two children the rock
was coming hitachi threw baby sasuke to
his mother
leaped up channeled chakra into his arm
so it was covered in faint blue flames
and punched the rock the rock exploded
and in this way a five-year-old itachi
saved his mother and brother his mother
mikoto chiha was a joni
she must have seen a lot over the course
of her life yet she still couldn't help
but be surprised
at the yangitachi's skills and instincts
thus by five years old
itachi had already shown himself to be
an awe-inspiring prodigy
at six years old itachi started the
ninja academy in general by the
beginning of naruto
it seems that most students enter the
academy at around 8 years old and then
spend 4 years there and graduate at 12
years old the rookie 9 or 12 when they
graduate even naruto who supposedly
failed the exam
twice before he took it a third time is
12. perhaps
naruto also started early like hitachi
while the others started at 8 which
could explain the confusion
anyways itachi excelled at the academy
there was a test where the students had
to hit 20 human figures
set up all over the schoolyard with
kunai as fast as possible
the rest of the classes average was
around 5 minutes and hitachi did it in
30 seconds
hitting every target with almost
flawless accuracy
in the head or the chest he scored a
perfect 100 on the test but hitachi
actually beat himself up about it he
compared himself to the older shisui who
could have done it faster and finally
decided that he could have shaved
another 5 seconds off
this is hitachi for you at 6 years old
he was not comparing himself to the
students around him but to the best of
chiha of the time
even a perfect score could be a failure
in hitachi's eyes
that's how hard he was on himself even
at six years old
itachi was so skilled that she sweet
trained with him they'd run about four
hours maintaining their top speed the
entire time
in contrast we're told anyone not
diligent with their ninja
training wouldn't have lasted five
minutes let alone four
hours shisui was known as shisui of the
body flicker
because of his insane speed so the fact
that hitachi could train and keep up
with him
as a kid is beyond impressive six months
after starting the academy
some teachers and students said that
hitachi's level of talent
had never before been seen at the school
the academy has been around since the
second hokage founded it so skilled
ninja like akashi the legendary 3 minato
and more have all gone through it and
some still
thought that hitachi had the most talent
we're even talking about people who
would eventually become great hokage so
let that sink in
just after four months at the academy
his teachers agreed to let him graduate
after his first year
i will say though that the hidden leaf
village was exhausted from the great war
and the attack of the ninetales so they
urgently needed ninja
thus select students were allowed to
graduate without waiting for their full
term to be up
prodigies like sasuke and neji would
have likely graduated early too
if they went through the system during
this period itachi passes the graduation
exam with no problem in contrast to
naruto who failed the graduation exam
three times hitachi had already mastered
clone techniques before he even
entered the academy so at only seven
years old aka five years before the
average student
he passed effortlessly another notable
example that perfectly illustrates how
hitachi was always a cut above the rest
can be found in the uniqueness
of his substitution technique most of
the time ninja switched out their own
body for a log
before an attack but hitachi used
countless crows instead of a log
i always used to think that this was
just itachi's own unique style but it
actually always served a specific
purpose as is explained in the novel and
i quote
if you used the usual log the confusion
effect on your opponent was meager
but the instant you switched out for
crows they flew off in all directions so
your opponent was surprised and
bewildered generating an
opening that wasn't even on the same
level as with the log
end quote so even little things like his
substitution technique were planned out
meticulously
by kiritachi for maximum effectiveness
donzo showed a huge interest in hitachi
because of his talent and according to
him and i quote
all involved assert that the academy has
never before witnessed
such a genius as hitachi end quote
that's the second time we've seen such a
statement
and in this case gonzo says all involved
rather than some teachers further
lending credence to the claim that
hitachi showed the most talent of all
at his graduation a seven-year-old
itachi chiha was valedictorian although
some people thought he was way too young
and others didn't want an uchiha to be
valedictorian
in the end they all bowed before his
overwhelming abilities and grades
and the way he excelled in all things he
had gotten nothing but perfect scores
while in the academy and completed the
graduation exam
flawlessly only four months after
entering he was the youngest
post-war graduate and valedictorian and
that post-war part is important because
other exceptional graduates like akashi
graduated during the great war
when there was an even more urgent need
of ninja thus for hitachi
it would not have been possible for him
to graduate at five years old
from the academy like akashi did and
after his graduation
donzo called him the most talented
genius ever to grace the halls of the
academy
so not only can we not place anyone
above him there is accumulating evidence
to indicate that kiritachi had the most
talent
out of everyone before him at the
academy at only 7 years old
itachi's practical abilities were
already set to be on par with the
average
tuning he fully awakened the shotgun at
8 years old and learned how to use it
then at 10 years old he officially got
promoted to chuni
he took the exam by himself and crushed
it even with an
unfair disadvantage for instance for the
second part of the tuning exams
hitachi completed it so fast that he set
a new record
despite the fact that the exam was based
on three-person cells
and he was working alone in contrast 10
year old sasuke would still be in the
academy for two years and would not
become a chunin
on his first try albeit there were weird
circumstances that interrupted the
tuning exams but shikamatu still got
promoted so it was possible although
sasuke
would eventually surpass hitachi
kiritachi was clearly more skilled in
advance
than kid sasuke and that's saying a lot
since sasuke was a prodigy and would go
on to become one of the two strongest
shinobi along with naruto but back to
hitachi
kiritachi would seriously spar with
shisui for hours
as i said shisui was considered to be
the strongest uchiha of his time
and a kititachi could spar with him for
hours in one instance
not only did he last 3 hours he even got
a good amount of wins
out of 15 rounds hitachi managed to win
6 compared to shisui who won
9. they weren't allowed to use the
shotting gun because that would waste
chakra and they wanted to fight for as
long as possible but that's crazy that
kiritachi was able to do that well
and sometimes win against the famous
shisui of the body flicker
at 11 itachi entered the on boo donzo
was pushing to make an 11 year old
hitachi on bu commander but usually an
unboo captain
had to be at least 13 years old as a
result of a compromise between dons on
the third hokage
itachi was promoted to anbu captain at
12 but his publicly disclosed promotion
age
was 13. itachi was around 13 years old
when he
with obito's help wiped out his entire
clan
except for sasuke he had his mangekyo
shotgun at this point
which he awakened after his best friend
shisui's death about a year earlier
in fact according to the novel hitachi
might have still been 12 since obito
tells hitachi
it's been four years since their first
meeting when he killed his teammate
tenma it was after this that hitachi
awakened his shutting god and he was 8
years old at the time
so 4 plus 8 is 12 years old if we take
his word super literally
but he would have been close to 13
nonetheless while his publicly disclosed
age
would have been around 14. as i
mentioned while the roughly 13 year old
itachi killed his clan
he had access to his unique mangekyo
shotgun powers he could use tsukuyomi
and amaterasu tsukiomi is again jutsu
that allowed hitachi to create an
illusion
for someone where hitachi completely
controlled time space and matter it said
in the novel that the time
that passed within this kanjutsu was one
one hundredth
of one one thousandth of one one
millionth of that of the real world
in other words a moment in the real
world could be experienced as a lifetime
for a person under the genjutsu even
though it can be used for torture
itachi could use it to create a kind of
paradise too so that people pass away
happily and tranquilly for instance he
used it on izumi
a girl that loved him and made her
experience an entire lifetime with
hitachi where they married had children
grew old together and so on in izumi's
case
she was smiling when she took her last
peaceful breath
killing her in this way also shows how
much hitachi cared about her
this was an important mission where he
needed all the strength and speed he
could muster the efficient thing to do
would have been to kill
izumi quickly with a blade but instead
hitachi chose to use tsukuyomi which
takes a huge toll on him
when he finished his body was shaking
because of the amount of chakra he used
up but he wanted to make sure that izumi
lived out her fantasies for a guy who on
missions is usually as
cold and calculating as a ninja can get
this act
shows that hitachi did have strong
feelings for izumi and might well have
married her
if the circumstances allowed it a
guesstimate that he didn't like at all
called yashiro hitachi used tsukuyomi to
create a world where infinite itachis
continued to stab the man with ninja
swords it was not even a few seconds in
the real world but yashiro
experienced several days of continuous
stabbings when hitachi stopped again
jutsu yashido's mind was destroyed
and then hitachi proceeded to chop off
his head as you can see hitachi despite
seemingly hating violence
could be quite cruel when angered we
also read about hitachi getting revenge
on
sugar aka yoji aburame who is the one to
blame for shisui's death
sugar had used insects to poison shisui
so that he would have died no matter
what hitachi deals with him and his
insects using a materasu the technique
produces black flames
that will not go out until whatever
hitachi is looking at has completely
burned he doesn't even let
one insect nesting in sugaru's body
escape amaterasu has been referred to as
the highest level of fire release
even though he becomes pretty useless in
later naruto at this point the materasu
was one of the best techniques in the
naruto world
along with tsukuyomi and since hitachi
has awakened the mangekyo shot again in
both eyes at this point
he at least has the potential to access
the power of susano too
with its incredible defensive and
offensive capabilities
even though he doesn't actually use it
in the novels it makes sense though that
hitachi doesn't use in the novels
because
he doesn't have a need for it he has no
problem strength wise
and taking out countless members of his
clan when it came to that it was more so
an emotional challenge than a physical
one and that's where we'll stop in the
story for the purposes of this video
up to about where hitachi is 13 years
old so we'll consider that kititachi and
if you want to see a video about adult
hitachi's true strength let me know in
the comments below
and by turning that like button blue in
that video i'll pick up where i left off
here but yeah i hope you have a better
sense of kitty touch he's insane power
potential
as we know he does develop an illness
but ignoring that his childhood could
easily lead one to believe that his
dream of becoming the strongest ninja in
the world
was possible he broke record after
record he not only completed the tuning
exams by himself
but also finished the forest of death
portion which is based on a three-man
cell in record time he was said multiple
times in the novels
to be the most talented ninja to ever
bless the halls of the academy
and yes some talented dudes didn't go to
the academy like the first and second
hokage for instance
because it wasn't formed yet but still
mina tokakashi and asanian went
and people still called hitachi the most
talented he trained and even won
sparring matches against shisui referred
to as the strongest uchiha of his age
when he was still a young kid he dreamt
of being the first uchiha hokage
and he easily reached hokage level not
only would he be clearly shown to
surpass kakashi and orochimaru in the
future
both of who were considered strong
enough to be hokage he even surpassed
his father fugaku in the novels
and as i mentioned manu chiha felt that
fugaku could have been
and should have been the fourth hokage
hitachi even attains the legendary
mangekyo shotting gun at around 12 years
old giving him access to opie jutsu like
amaterasu tsukuyomi and potentially
susanoo
skill wise the sky was the limit for
kititachi it's unfortunate that he got
ill
but without tailed beast powers sage of
six path powers
or reincarnation of someone famous
powers hitachi did just about as well as
you can expect someone to do in fact one
might even argue that he surpassed
all expectations for how strong he could
have reasonably hoped to be
and that is it for this video thank you
to everyone who suggested an itachi
dedicated video
and if you did enjoy this one make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
and to unlock the video for adult
hitachi
let's aim for getting over 5 000 likes
on this one
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future naruto
videos
as you wait for the next naruto video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
naruto playlist
which includes videos about the hokage
uchiha clan uzumaki clan
and more a very special thank you goes
out to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola and
atem the world steelers acquire respect
pate heffer jonathan king brandon of
isles
papa smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez
thomas jones ken mono michael hyde and
jaden the vector controller
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris
anatoly kazatsuki angel crews cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie park zodiar12
rethu and day aura
kraken aurel's deadly saint and stern
hawkins thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support morbid by going over to
patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you get a name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
youtube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you